hi good morning John I'll put a hike
with Catherine and lemon what's the
difference for a hike in a walk
definitely harder than my average walk
going uphill I want to make a couple of
points in this video today neither of
them have anything to do with what's
going on around me but hopefully you
will find that stuff interesting as well
we're out here hunting for wildflowers
and we're also looking for a geocache do
caching is fun you know geocaching
reminds me of it reminds me of YouTube a
lot of cool people coming together and
doing fun things and sometimes you know
troll comes in and spoils it for
everybody but most the time there's just
a lot of people who want to do something
fun together
do you caching for those who don't know
is these little practice of hiding stuff
and then leaving the GPS coordinates
behind and the people can come and find
your cache and they can add stuff to the
cache and take stuff out of the cache
and leave their name in the logbook it's
super fun I was going to show you me
finding the geocache but I can't find it
which is embarrassing one of the two big
points that I want to make this video
though is that YouTube is important
YouTube is important interesting and
fascinating on so many levels and it's
freaking awesome but here's my real
point what stuff is important mountains
are important oxygen is important PVC
pipes are important motherboards are
important motherhood is important in all
of these things are important saying
that what you're doing is important
isn't unusual the second thing that I
want to add to this is that important
doesn't equal serious I think personally
fun is like the most important thing out
there except for trying to make the
world a better place fun man and I get
so angry when people start to make it
about being serious because you know
what fun is important Stephenie Meyer is
important Austin Powers is important
Weird Al Yankovic is important and I
don't care who hears me say it John and
nerdfighters I think that we are all so
lucky to be in new media where we don't
have to take things so seriously and the
last thing I want honestly is for this
to become serious business because then
you start to lose the fun
oh that's login night that's fun and
beautiful that's what I want for us I
cannot express how lucky I feel that I
can go outside on a beautiful day and
share my thoughts with so many
interesting and thoughtful people so
lucky and I hope that we can distinguish
between important and serious because to
me serious has never even been on the
agenda what's on the agenda is important
fun this is important fun let's have it
John I will see you on Friday
we found it we found it isn't that
exciting link right there this is the
logbook